your dad is [__] awesome he's a good
man this is a man who was hospitalized
because he ate too much pizza correct
exactly two or three Christmas ago he
ate like an entire tray of lasand right
like the entire tray was supposed to be
his wife put it out for like the party
and my dad down the whole tray that's
[__] aw and she was like Tony that
was for the
party and then that night I was sleeping
over I wake up what happen he you father
can't breathe I'm like holy sh so we get
get him to the hospital the next morning
you know one of the doctors comes and
says listen does have congestive heart
failure the beginnings of stage one
congestive heart failure you know
honestly he probably has like a year or
two like people just don't live long
with this eight hours later they call me
they say hey a mini Miracle has happened
they said we just reran his blood and
his congestive heart failure is gone and
they said what we think happened was is
he had so much sodium in one sitting
that he actually fooled our EKG machines
into thinking he had congested more
failure